las cosas empezaron bien para las
relaciones de manuel macrón con argelia
cuando estaba haciendo campaña para las
elecciones presidenciales de 2017 hizo
eco en el país africano y en francia
cuando llamo a la colonización un crimen
contra la humanidad y la colonización
fue para sí mismo la colonización es
parte de la historia de francia es un
crimen un crimen contra la humanidad
realmente bárbaro es parte de un pasado
con el que tenemos que lidiar pidiendo
disculpas a las víctimas de nuestras
acciones
miserias pero el año pasado las
relaciones empeoraron cuando francia
anunció que reduciría drásticamente el
número de visas otorgadas argelinos y
otros ciudadanos del norte de áfrica la
disputa se profundizó cuando macrón hizo
comentarios sobre la historia de argelia
al diario francés l monto
hubo una nación argelina antes del
colonialismo francés esa es la cuestión
había otras potencias coloniales
argel retiró a su embajador en parís y
cerró su espacio aéreo a los aviones
militares franceses a principios de 2021
makro encargó un informe sobre el
colonialismo pero la recepción en argel
no fue la esperada con medios de
comunicación y caricaturas como esta del
famoso dibujante ally dilema destacando
la ausencia de disculpa y
arrepentimiento
francia se niega a disculparse por su
pasado colonial los argelinos les
entierran el hacha de guerra macrón ha
logrado sumar algunos puntos en medio de
la disputa diplomática condenó una
sangrienta represión contra los
manifestantes argelinos por parte de la
policía en parís en 1961 calificándola
de crimen imperdonable y reconociendo
que decenas de personas habían muerto la
declaración más fuerte hasta ahora de un
político francés otra manzana de la
discordia en las relaciones bilaterales
es la devolución de los archivos
coloniales una demanda que argel repite
a menudo